how has this
ever since it came out hurt america how
has it
helped so what's been the positive
impact and the negative impact
well it sounds extreme to say that i
cannot think of any positive impact
but it's true i cannot think of any
positive impact any
none none i cannot think of any because
it's a parasite it's a fraud it's based
on
a lie it's it's a it's a cartel now we
have to understand
when a cartel is formed it has only one
purpose
and that's to advance the benefit of the
members of the cartel
period anything beyond that i mean
if you were president or an executive
officer of a oil cartel
and you started talking about what's
good for the people of venezuela
or or or you know mexico and
maybe we ought to cut our prices and our
profit margins so we can
benefit the poor people of mexico you'd
be out of a job in a heartbeat
so the same thing is true with a banking
cartel they have to talk
endlessly about stabilizing the economy
and
you know making jobs and and
preserving the purchase power of the
dollar and all these good things
but in their hearts no that's that's
just for cover
all they're concerned about is what is
best for the banks
and if you doubt that just take a look
at the report card if we were to give
the federal reserve system a report card
from 1913
on when it was formed supposedly to
stabilize
the purchasing power of the dollar let's
say and to provide
you know all these good benefits for the
people it would
it would fail it'd be at failing marks
all the way down it has never succeeded
in doing that
it's it's led us into a couple of the
greatest depressions you can imagine
it's leading us into a huge depression
any day now it's already happening
and the state the purchasing power of
the dollar is has lost 90
97 since 1913 it takes
yeah 97 of the purchasing power of the
dollar
has been lost since 1913 under the
guidance of the federal reserve system
how do you come up with that number how
how is that number when you say 97
percent
that means it's three cents to a dollar
how do you come up with that number 97
percent those numbers come from the
federal reserve system itself
believe it or not because there are
studies on what what is inflation what's
the inflationary
effect and the those numbers are really
easy to find by the way
uh it's kind of hard to distort them
they're just hard numbers what does it
cost to buy
a pound hamburger you know in 1913 or
today
what does it cost for a quart of milk or
a gallon of gas and they they have these
baskets of things they keep changing it
to try and soften the impact but no
matter how often they
change it uh even in my lifetime i
remember for
for a penny you know talk about penny
candy and those for a penny i could go
to a candy store and get a nice big
chunk of candy
one that cost me a dollar today you know
or
or 50 cents for sure anyway they these
numbers are
readily available and so uh if anybody
wants to
doubts it and i don't blame them because
it's a harsh figure look it up
it's you'll find it easily on the
internet 97
has been the purchasing power has been
eroded
uh since 1913. so
um the federal reserve which is supposed
to be the guardian
to prevent all of this stuff gets a
failing remark on its report card
but now if you understand as i learned
that that is not the goal of the federal
reserve
the federal reserve reserve is not a
government agency it's not formed to
protect the people
it's the cartel it's formed to protect
the banks
now if you realize that that is their
goal and gave another report card
man they get all a's because the banks
always get bailed out every time they
get into trouble
the banks may fail but they get the
taxpayers to cough up the money somehow
and they're back in business again doing
all their same tricks again
the banks are always making record
profits and
so we understand it's a cartel and on
that basis it gets all straight a's
[Music]